المعيه الاسرائيليه سقطت على هذا المنزل
الذي كان بداخلها عدد من المواطنين جالسين
وامنين بعد ان قصفت هذه المدفعيه بقذائف
تم نقل عدد من المصابين من هنا باتجاه
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلاح بجوار
هذا المكان هنا ايضا عدد من خيام النازحين
الذين قد اصيبوا جراء هذه الغاره
الاسرائيليه والتي من خلالها اطلقت
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه قذيفه على ما يبدو
سقطت في منزل احد المواطنين هنا وهذا
الامر ادى الى وقوع عدد من الاصابات وصلوا
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح في هذه
الاثناء يتم استخراج عدد من المصابين ايضا
من المنطقه المستهدفه بالقذائف
المدفعيه كما تشاهدون و عدد من المواطنين
الذين اصيبوا بجراح في
هذه غاره
الاسرائيليه حسبنا الله عل حسبنا الله ايش
اللي صار يا خالتي ايش اللي صار بغص في
الدار عذار بنتي وعذار ابن عمي كلهم ولا
70 نفر في الدار حسبنا الله عليهم بدون
سابق انظار بدون سابق انذار شهداء وجار
حالهم بالمستشفى حسبنا الله عليهم حسبنا
الله ونعم الوكيل على كل من تفرج
علينا ما عمل شيء حسبنا الله ايش اصابات
بين الاطفال في اصابات اه بين الاطفال في
من شهيدين الحين يطلعو انادي
عار
الله يرضى عليك الله يرضى
عليك حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل حسبنا الله
ونعم
الوكيل الحمد
لله الحمد لله الحمد لله يا رب الحمد لله
بنتي بين ايدي استشهدت بنتي صم ما بتسمعش
ايش عامله 18 سنه ارعه موقعه ايش عامله
للناس
لا اله
الافض
المقاومه نفض المقاومه الله معهم الله
يسندهم هذه اصابات تاتي في هذه الاثناء
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح حيث
اطلقت المدفعيه الاسرائيليه عدد من
قذائفها بتجاه منازل
المواطنين
مازالت سياره الاسعاف تنقل مصابين الى
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح حيث اطلقت المدفعيه الاسرائيليه في
منطقه
الزوايده عدد من قذائفها باتجاه منازل
المواطنين الامنين جل الاصابات التي
تاتي هم من
الاطفال والنساء
والمدنيين فر
الاطفال يلاز على
السريع